the anima is the archetype of life and
it is
when when the anima is negative it is
the impulse to dream about life and to
make wishful fantasies about life
instead of living life and that's why
uh vampires and draculas and
the creatures alike always suck one's
blood
the blood is the emotional active psyche
in us
the affect psyche and such people have
no
activity left or no life activity left
they just
sink into a passive wishful dream
the dream tries to tell him it's a ghost
which is haunting me
because actually he's haunted not by
realities haunted by a fantasy
which is draining his whole psychic
energy at the end of the dream the man's
unable to escape from the vampire
it's going to suck the blood out of them
how would you interpret that
that is really the characteristic of
most
negative or split-off complexes if we
reject or split off some complex of
our psyche then it begins to sap our
energy secretly behind our back so to
speak
and then he turns slowly into what
what is aptly represented by the image
of the vampire something which attacks
us in the night and sucks all our blood
people feel they don't know they
they come into analysis and they say i
feel listless i just feel
tired i i just don't want to do anything
i wake up already in the morning
depressed
nothing means anything to me anymore
they are
we could answer to them you are probably
sucked by a vampire you are bloodless
you have no life impulse no
no pleasure in life anymore no interest
or anything
and then you generally find that this
vampire is just a split-off complex
which has been
split off so radically and
so powerfully that it can only
sap energy anymore it cannot manifest in
any other way anymore
why are the movies about deaf goddesses
and vampires so popular
i think all movies which touch
essential psychological
facts the movies nowadays more or less
replace the fairy tale telling
and and the myth telling it's our modern
form of myth and fairy tales
and therefore movies which tell about
the inner world like fairy tales do are
much more attractive to the public
because we really need myths to have an
orientation or to have
mapping out the the dream world or the
unconscious
and in past time there were the
innumerable
myths of vampires and
which fascinated people tales retold all
over the world
in china for instance you have a whole
host of
ghost stories where a man meets a fox
and then the fox turns uh he
is really the ghost of the dead and
turns up as a beautifully
made up girl and he has a marvelous life
with her till one day he discovered
that she is an evil demon she is a
skeleton
and then sometimes he dents a badge he
pulls him into death or
he can with the help of priests and
magicians free himself from the demon
and we for instance in the swiss alps we
have stories that our
cowherds high up in the mountain who
have to live there
the whole summer alone without having
women every night that darkly comes
that is a female ghost comes through the
the door invisibly and rides the null
the night
and they they have so that they have
sexual pollutions
and in the morning they wake up
completely exhausted and
can't practically move anymore
overwhelmed so to speak bisexual
fantasies and by
the unlived life if the man's feelings
are locked in
to the mother complex if his life is
being sucked away by the vampire
and how can he transform those feelings
how can he get free of the mother
complex
i i once made the dream of a young man
who had who was living still with mama
he was 29
and had never had a girl in his room
and so we seriously discussed the
possibility of getting a room
outside his mother's home and he was
terrified
he he was a very sensitive delicate boy
and
his mother was a very brutal strong
personality
and he was just terrified of of the
moment to tell mother look here i am
going to take
a room outside and i'm not going to live
with you anymore
and when he was kind of trying to make
up his mind he dreamt
that he had to slay the dragon so that
in that case it means actually that
though it seems such a
to us little thing to tell mother i have
to room for him that was slaying the
dragon
it was overcoming a monstrous
neurotic difficulty within himself his
whole mother complex
not only facing the scene of his actual
mother
but overcoming also the inertia
and the anxiousness
of his own mother complex his mother had
sowed in him
an anxiousness a fear of life he had to
overcome a terrific fear of life
to make that step and
that is an archetypal motive all over
the
place that the young man has to do the
heroic deed of killing his mother or the
mother dragon or the mother demon
which is what is anxious
or lazy or afraid of living a masculine
life